on this episode I film the show right
before I take the stage a good day New
York
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
everybody this is gary vay-ner-chuk and
this is episode 119 of the ask gary vee
show um we're in some sort of room here
I'm about to go on good day New York
co-hosting guys you know let's talk
about the people that have crossed over
but you know Michael Strahan Mary o
Lopez you know listen also I think when
you really think about it anybody that's
co-hosted or hosted morning shows has
really come from somewhere else and so
maybe this is a preview to me one day
being the host of Good Morning America I
don't think so but I'm excited about it
my mom's more excited about it so from
9:00 to 10:00 a.m. today in New York
City tri-state area on FOX five I will
be the co-host of a show I'm gonna do a
little segment on wine so that should be
fun little throwback Monday for me big
shout out to the entire vaynernation I
really appreciate the tremendous words
and kind remarks from episode 118 a
little impromptu we decide to play
basketball
India texted me said she got choked up
many of you did I really appreciate that
so with that India do you recommend the
move let's get into the show
the show that was a good one I had to
sell you out if you were people that
watch it backwards you'll see I set you
up for it
I made a movement and it caught you
let's get right into it because I've got
again on the air
Galen asks how would you market to Amish
people if that was your primary market
hashtag buggy hustle Galen this is a
tremendous question I think it opens up
an opportunity for me to give a broad
answer the truth is I'd probably spend
six months to a year before I would say
a word or mark it for me personally
because I completely under educated on
that market I don't know what that what
makes that market tick what are they you
know obviously what if anything are they
buying you know obviously I'm I'm not
deeply knowledgeable obviously I have
headlines on what I think is going on
their preconceived notions but I've
learned in my 40 years of life
those tend to lead you to disaster when
you're making assumptions on the market
when you don't intimately know it you
know for me the two core businesses I've
run in my career the wine business and
an agency that markets within social
media if you pay attention closely there
were markets that I spent five seven
eight years being deeply in before I
took the reins one obviously in a family
business growing up and into really
participating in it being a thought
leader within it jamming with it using
it and that I mean I was using social
media hard court for you know five six
years before I started vaynermedia to
then give advice around it and so that's
what I would do and that's what I think
a lot of you are making huge mistakes on
interacting with so many of you on
Instagram Facebook Twitter I noticed
this quick you know I want to sell
sneakers right I want to be in a sneaker
game and yeah you kind of like sneakers
but do you understand the sneaker
business
I don't want with the you know huge
pause there Stefan for a specific reason
when you decide to jump into business
yeah you mean like wine but do you
understand the wine business you may
have a Twitter account but you
understand social media business yeah
you may have some kicks and have six or
seven pairs or even fifty but do you
understand the sneaker business and so
if I'm marketing I'm in business and if
I don't understand the market if I don't
people II understand the competitive
landscape the supply and demand chain
out what I'm gonna do the marketing
opportunities the white space that I
love to play in so much that I'm gonna
lose and that's why so many people lose
they confuse enthusiasm or or hobby for
business skills and so before you do
anything before you jump into anything I
highly recommend if so many of you
starting t-shirt companies without doing
a hardcore audit of the fifty hundred
t-shirt companies in the market and what
they're doing and how much they're
spending do your damn homework Daniel
asks I've started a startup that many
others have tried to do before me and
failed my stupid to think that I'll be
the anomaly Dan it's a tough question
because the truth is there are some
mountains that are very difficult to
climb and thesis is that people love to
think a real
and they're never able to really fully
get there I think the anonymous social
network space is going to end up being
one of them I think that brings out the
worst in people and ultimately kills
itself from within itself
that's one preview to a space that I'm
not bullish on that I think a lot of
people who try to climb that mountain
that said it just takes one tweak one
turn you know there was there was a lot
of industries where people couldn't
figure out how to win and then
eventually somebody came along and won
that game and so I think that very
similar to the first answer in this in
this episode it comes down to your chops
your skills your patience your
infrastructure and it really really
really does come down to your skill set
I really do believe that um you know
anybody can do anything if they're good
enough if they're the first of that
thing I just think that people have to
be very realistic to also understand how
special and rare that actually is Nathan
asks I'm in the middle of transitioning
to a new job I was wondering what your
advice would be for my last two weeks
Nathan I'm gonna give you some really
good advice that I think a lot of people
here need to hear as you transition from
job to job actually think the last two
weeks of your job are one of the most
interesting times you can have in your
career it's something that I've spent a
lot of time on paying attention to the
behavior of people that have spent last
two weeks at Wine Library or vaynermedia
I think that I think that your actions
in those two weeks will really be much
more impactful on your future career
than you may realize
I think the Grace and being the bigger
man or woman and humility and all the
things that come along with it are all
those great traits that I like to talk
about pretty often are so imperatives in
in those last two weeks because
everybody's watching your co-workers are
watching and definitely your employer's
watching it's stunning to me how many
people have come back around in a year
later at vaynermedia asking me for help
asking for a job back when they were
actually terrible or not terrible it's
not fair I was I'm very competitive you
know they were you know oh I'm going to
this great gig and like trying to impact
other people to make them realize how
they're going
this amazing place and and it's funny
how the grass is not as green once you
land on your new location and then when
you're lucky enough to work for somebody
who's a good guy and it has some power
and then you go ask for something what
all you had to do was be the bigger
woman for those two weeks and I would go
out of my way to help you I think way
too many people burn bridges on the way
out bridges that they need because the
short-sighted nature of our society much
of the themes of the 200 episodes 150
episodes or 120 episodes Lou
how are you man can you give this man a
little bit of depth let me ask every
show I know he watches it how are you
thanks for having me on I've been away
on social media saying I love it I'm
excited let me finish this she'll be
with you in a second
I think burning those bridges is a
devastating play that way too many
people feel out of excitement sometimes
or out of you know cynicism and all the
negative things that then kind of makes
me feel that it's fair that they're
unable to mend those relationships and
get value out of those past
relationships to me there's no value in
anything other than being over-the-top
awesome giving love to everybody making
amends with people maybe that you didn't
work well with the last two weeks I
think you treat it like the last month
of high school senior year right you
just make it all good Nils asks if you
were to make a video game what type
would it be and on what platform would
you sell it it was just a pretty
interesting question there's two spaces
that I think video games are really
interesting and one is obviously mobile
I still think mobile kind of word simple
like the game that works for the
thirteen-year-old and for the 84 year
old grandmother are always super
interesting to me very basic you know
just simple word brain quizzes you know
hangman 3.0 that kind of stuff is super
interesting but the place that I
probably go since I love so much the
game of following where I think the puck
is going to be is I'd probably make a
virtual reality game one that had you
know kind of like the Zelda a VR which
was a completely open world where he
could do a whole lot of stuff I don't
know if I would go shooter though I
think that's gonna be the breakout win
early on
I'm a little bit more into like Gauntlet
really affected me in the early days of
one of the first four player arcade
games and made my boys back in 84 would
roll into chuck-e-cheese with quarters
for days and just get down with that and
I was always pumped to be the princess
by the way everybody would fight for the
wizard like I'll be princess she's good
she was nasty
anyway so I would say some sort of
open-ended Zelda gauntlet adventure type
game for virtual reality that I don't
think would pop for another 24 to 36
months but if you follow the narrative
of my 20 year career and hopefully what
I do in the next 40 years I'm always
going to bet on where I think the
markets gonna be 24 36 months from now
use my disproportional ability to sell
to keep me afloat for those 24 to 36
months and then be there where the
market is gonna be there when I started
selling social media at the brands in
2009 they didn't want to buy it only now
only as we head into 2016
budgets am I starting to see some real
upside and as you can imagine that bodes
well for my business I would do the same
thing in the video game industry why
just crashed on you cool hey Gary this
is Britt McCallion and my question for
you for the askgaryvee show is what
women in business do you think are just
rocking it on social media I love to
follow people who are doing great stuff
and I'd love to know who you think is
doing an exceptional job on social media
women in business thank you hungry in
business social media this is tough for
me for a couple of reasons one I really
don't follow anybody you know all I'm
really doing is putting out content and
engaging with my own audience and so I'm
not trying to duck the question
obviously there's plenty of people that
pop to mind that I think are incredible
entrepreneurs and business women you
know
katia CEO of Birchbox an investment of
mine obviously since I'm an investor in
it I'm a little bit closer to it I think
she's an incredible operator an
entrepreneur Rachel from Micmac another
investment that I've made that I'm in
love with Brit Brit Morin is probably
crushing it Brit Co another investment
of mine these are businesses that I'm
closer to you know Spoon University
gals that are crushing it again I have
no clue what they're doing on social I
know what they're doing in marketing in
operating and leadership and being a CEO
I assume Britt is doing a great job
because their brand is at the forefront
and I have seen stuff in the past but
I've been very head down for the last 24
months really on this show and running
vaynermedia and obviously the vayner/rse
venture capital stuff so I've been a
little busy though I did truth is and
I'm just gonna let it add it back I've
never really followed anybody because I
just don't have the time for it and I'm
really gonna only do my thing anyway
which could be a weakness by the way I
don't think this is some great oh I'm so
cool some amazing strength that I don't
follow anybody else
it's just how I roll and as I always say
here you need to do you so I apologize
that I'm a great answer to that question
savvy auntie historically has done an
amazing job I'm a big fan so those are
some of the answers tight show very
focused I think what you're seeing in my
demeanors I'm starting to get mentally
prepared for the show that I'm gonna be
doing it not the show but the show I'm
doing today
question of the day what female
entrepreneur is killing it on social
media if I can't answer it you guys will
you keep asking questions I'll keep
answering them
oh yeah one last thing from today's
episode next Friday not this but yes
next Friday the 31st I'm going to be
flying in three of you to take over D
Rock Stefan Steve on what that's done
one India all of their jobs for the
one-year anniversary of the askgaryvee
show I'm picking three superfans fill
out the form they're all handling that
we'll get you more info on that but do
you reckon maybe you take over to thing
I don't know what hit it but bottom line
is 3-view are coming next Friday to take
over the crews job hang out with us we
have a meeting it's gonna be a full
askgaryvee experience for three of you I
hope you win I hope you picked
good luck so if you're available fill
out the form and I'll see you in eat
what is it seven like 11 days whatever
[Music]